After our guests saw the life-changing effects
of a good makeover,
they created a non-profit dedicated
to helping women in need.
And the organization is called My Fairy Godfathers
and founders Steven Anderson
and Andrew Ashton are here with us now.
Hi guys.
(audience cheering)
Hey!
Hi Drew!
Nice to see you.
How are you?
Oh my God!
You guys look like fairy godfathers.
Like, like I see you and you've got that smile and you look
like you're awake and alive
and like ready to fly in and change people's lives.
I can see it all over you.
Our wings are in the back.
We took them off.
That's it.
I see the wings, I do.
(Steven and Andrew laughing)
It's the glimmer in your eye
and the smiles on your faces.
And Stephen, as a hairstylist
you say that like seeing the confidence
in a woman after she gets a haircut,
it inspired you to do something even more beautiful.
Can you explain that?
Well, yeah, I mean, we work on women every single day.
We work on men and women, but women primarily, and you know
those few minutes that we're in the chair
with that person, you make a change.
We make them feel really good.
But we were approached to help a young girl
go to the prom if we would donate hair and makeup to her.
And we did, we said, sure, we would do that.
But we decided we would take it a little bit further.
We asked her about her dress.
She said she had a dress.
And then we looked at it and we said,
"Ooh, no, can't do that."
So we decided to create a dress for her
and it just kind of blossomed from there.
And when we finished with the whole transformation,
she looked at herself and she's like,
"Wow, you guys are like my fairy godfathers."
And that's kind of how the name stuck.
Well, and Andrew, you've worked with some women
who are facing some serious issues.
And I was wondering if you would tell me about these women.
Oh, wow.
You know, we've helped over 750 women so far,
since Stephen and I began this journey.
And we've worked with women that have
been through catastrophic illness
or through financial hardship
and a lot of times beyond their control.
So we just felt like we needed to go in
and let them feel their beauty again
and feel confident and empowered.
And I think sometimes when you feel low,
when you're going through catastrophic illness
and you've had to cut off all your hair,
if you're going through chemo,
you just wanna feel like yourself.
You wanna feel beautiful again.
And so that's why we created the, you know
give wigs to women that are going through all this.
And we sit with them and we talk with them
and we style them out
and we go through everything that we need to
to make them feel beautiful again.
Well, we actually reached out to some these women,
You did?
(Stephen laughing)
Yeah, we have a little surprise for you.
Check this out.
Oh, no way!
(inspiring music)
Hi, Steven and Andrew, it's been so long
since I've been able to be blessed with your presence.
I definitely want to say thank you
for everything that you did for me.
I left my senior prom feeling
like I was ready for the world.
When I met them, I was lost.
I just didn't know there was more to life.
Like they helped me realize that.
To have My Fairy Godfathers be able to step in,
in a moment where I needed them most
was so instrumental in my journey and my confidence.
As a mom watching your child battle cancer,
it was just the social part of it,
about feeling beautiful.
And they just wanted to make her feel
like a pretty princess.
I mean, I...
Having my baby girl with me,
seeing her face lit up because my face lit up,
and her, you know, seeing my confidence.
That is what the organization's about.
It means more than just a wig.
They gave me my power back.
My fairy godfathers forever.
You are life changing.
Thank you for what you're doing for women like myself.
Thank you for making me feel
like myself again and make me feel beautiful.
Oh my God.
Oh my God. That's great.
I love to see people that have been in the past.
I'm sorry, because it shows, it shows
that we made a difference for them
in the short period of time that we were with them
and the experiences that we can give to them,
hopefully they'll remember for their lifetime.
So sorry.
(Stephen laughing)
No, I mean, what do you feel right now,
out of curiosity?
Oh, my heart is full.
It's just full of happiness.
It's wonderful.
That was a great surprise.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, so much.
That was great.
It's all both of you.
And you guys are changing so many lives
and as a thank you, by the way,
I started a beauty company 10 years ago, Flower Beauty,
and we are gonna send you a ton of stuff.
I'm talking thousands of dollars worth of -
Thank you.
Great, thank you so much!
hair tools and makeup,
so that you have that at your disposal.
And we also want to send you each $5,000
totaling in 10.
(audience cheering)
Just, you know, a little something to help
aid and foster what you are already doing.
Listen, this money doesn't compare.
This is our way of saying thank you
to you and wanting to support
and foster what you are already doing.
Aw, Thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
We really appreciate you having us.
Thank you.
Go to our website to learn all about My Fairy Godfathers.
(uplifting music)